ce qui est terrible c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est plus du tout sur un discours
avec madame la ministre barbara pompili
sur un discours du bien-être animal
on est sur un discours qui est
complètement différent puisqu'elle est
entouré d'un petit cette liste
d'associations de soi disant protection
animale et de weygand on oublie le
bien-être animal
on lui a remis il ya dix jours en
arrière un dossier qui lorsque c'était
elisabeth banques qui étaient à la place
de barbara pompili où on explique bien
qu'on a déjà travaillé sur le sujet que
tout le monde sait plier à des règles
qui étaient encore plus draconiennes
pour l'itinérance pour les cirques pour
le bien-être de l'animal
elle l'a même pas regardé parce qu'elle
est elle dirigée par ces anti sexiste
mais tout ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans très peu de temps
on pourra même plus avoir de chien qui
vont sauver les gens dans les
inondations
oui dans le sud de la france pour aller
sur leurs deux chiens dans les montagnes
qui sont délaissés pour aller chercher
un humain te plairait sous une avalanche
éculés on ne pourra plus avoir de chien
d'aveuglé savoir deux chiens policiers
ont gelé ces gens sont contre la
présence de l'animal nos animaux sont
nés en captivité au cirque
ils ont l'habitude de l'itinérance izem
l'itinérance je suis un professionnel et
un amoureux des animaux et je vois
actuellement chez nous à pain verlande
une certaine tristesse pour millions oui
de ne pas voyager parce que c'est
toujours la même je voudrais revenir un
peu en arrière d'abord sur les mesures
qui ont été annoncées est ce qu'il ya eu
des concertations entre non les
professionnels et la ministre première
que j'ai rencontré une tuyère vincent
hullin qui est son conseiller
biodiversité
qu'a bien voulu m'entendre j'étais
accompagné du président du président du
syndicat des capacités c'est à dire tous
les gens dans notre profession pur un
certificat de caciques capacités pour
avoir ce des animaux sauvages et pour
les présenter en spectacle est également
le le président des animaux de cirque et
des animaux de spectacle ils ont omis
vous le disait un dossier à madame
sorbara pompili il ya dix jours en
arrière elle ne l'a même pas regardé ça
fait trois ans déjà qu'on augmente le
bien-être animal on est encore prêt nous
gens de cirque les petits cirques de
famille à faire - d'itinérance à rester
trois semaines à moi dans les villes a
abandonné ce qui est un problème alors
attendez améliorer encore le bien-être
animal avec des enclos encore plus grand
mais c'est un discours qui est clos on
ne nous écoute pas on est quand même là
tu me dis que barbara pompidou elle nous
écoutent matin à l'école mais tu me dis
que c'était avant l été pour
mais au début nos choix d'une peur au
début elle était pas pauvres comme les
gens mais surtout l'art du conte parce
que vous savez que le public sait de
partout que les animaux sont bien c'est
pour ça que les gens viennent au cirque
y'a pas de problème encore là
actuellement chez claudio zavatta est un
petit cirque avec lequel j'étais l'année
dernière ils remplissent pas ce que les
gens se rendent bien compte et le savent
que les animaux sont bien alors
maintenant il joue sur un autre truc il
joue sur la soi-disant itinérance moi je
suis un professionnel je connais mes
animaux je connais tous les animaux du
cirque et ceux de mes confrères les
bêtes m l'itinérance arrêtez de dire ils
sont pâles bringuet dans des camions
chauffer surchauffe elles étaient
frigorifiés l'été c'est pas vrai tout
c'est moi j'ai quelques arguments à vous
opposer mais olivier chaud bouillant ce
soit je donne ma part le pire oui je
sais pas vraiment ce monsieur en fait je
le connais en fait depuis une vingtaine
d'années à toulouse et en fait moi ce
monsieur m'a prouvé que en fait
excusez moi de dire ça mais c'est ses
chats vous rentrez dans sa caravane ils
sont couchés sur la banquette
vous rentrez dedans vous faites niggli
fait ni mort mais qu'il faut pas que ce
soit il dit m
ce monsieur ça retourne à sa place à
l'endroit où ça doit aller
donc on peut dire ce qu'on veut
l'itinérance machin ces animaux on était
fait pour être avec l'humain le papa qui
l'a élevé qui lie à donner le biberon
bercy qui l'a amené jusqu'à sanad son
adolescence et de son adolescence
tiendra c'est lyon adultes à qui
aujourd'hui il peut se coucher entre ces
quatre jammes et ne lui mordre annie la
gorge
ni l'agent ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que dans le milieu naturel à
l'heure actuelle c'est une véritable
barbarie oui je pense à mon copain yvan
landry est le patron du
de venise c'est pareil c'est un petit
cirque de famille mais tous les animaux
sont bien dans les petites salles de
famille il me dit c'est la barbarie là
bas oui pourquoi parce que les réserves
sont des réserves de chasse où on va
tuer de griffe et 12 deux tours ont fait
je les ai sauvé justement de ces
trophées de lion blanc devait prononcer
à se faire shooter pour 15000 dollars
la base c'est la mort assurée plus vous
savez qu'il ya toute la déforestation
c'est un véritable problème pour les
animaux ils sont en voie de disparition
vous avez un véritable problème aussi
avec le changement climatique
il ya beaucoup de choses les ours
polaires qui perdent leur leur banquise
les animaux sont en voie de disparition
dans leur milieu naturel les nouvelles
ont découvert mal à dire les nouvelles
maladies
je remettrai pas nos animaux dans la
nature ils sont pas faits pour chacun